toi de lui j'accueille banque baer
boehner dans le soir justement il est
libre maintenant à nay elle sait pas
encore il avait de la retouche ou bien
alors on vous avez 50 ans bob berre et
vous êtes un ex-cadre de la cia
vous êtes entrain la cia en 1976
pourquoi un jeune homme chic habitué à
faire du ski à aspen et à faire des
voyages en europe at-il postuler pour
entrer la cia et au sort oui c'était
super romantique permis de voyager a mis
du piment dans ma vie d'un moment ben
j'ai pris goût salle de bain nous
agirons oui mais bon c'était une
expérience n'écoute pas comme ça
derrière
comment comment vous appeler monsieur
olivier un bon soir les vieilles soit
bien alors que j'allais pourquoi avoir
quitté la cia vingt ans plus tard
vous voyez la cia s'était trop politisé
à mon goût et donc j'avais l'impression
de perdre mon temps et donc j'ai tenté
ma chance ailleurs
montréal bien alors pendant vingt ans
vous avez combattu l'islamisme sur tous
les fronts c'est surtout sa jeudi à
beyrouth à sarajevo en irak 95 j'ai
essayé de faire tomber sa dame je vais
monter une petite équipe au nord de
l'irak malheureusement ça n'a pas été un
succès dépêche toi un peu olivier lassus
apple sur foot + vient alors le livre du
grand bleu vif dont on va parler ce soir
c'est votre deuxième livre bob le
premier s'appelait la chute de la cia
qui était un best-seller aux etats-unis
et qui va être bientôt adapté au cinéma
par soderbergh pour la warner voilà
c'est pas c'est pas n'importe qui
alors votre nouveau s'appelle l'or noir
et la maison blanche comment l'amérique
a vendu son âme pour le pétrole saoudien
essai publié chez jean retour de la
thèse une question est ce que la cia
sait des choses que les présidents ne
savent pas où est ce qu ils obligés de
tout dire au président louis quoi de
temps en temps il ya certaines choses
qui se passaient les présidents seront
pas au courant mais bon ça on n'en parle
pas du tout et c'est très rare mais bon
je ne peux pas tout vous dire c'est que
je suis
olivier j'aimerais bien alors le pit va
vous révéler bob burke il ya un pacte
qui unit les élites économiques et
politiques américaines à la famille
royale saoudienne voilà en gros c'est ce
qui ressort de votre chercheurs de votre
bouquin alors dans votre livre des
passages qui sont supprimées et des
passages qui sont caviardés alors vous
les avez vous les avez laissé mes mais
barré quoi c'est à dire vous êtes obligé
de montrer tout ce que vous écrivez la
cia fallu que je m y que la cia il a
fallu qu'ils regardent retire certains
passages l'essentiel est là et je
remercie laisser y aller alors il y
avait quoi dans ces passages barré dans
les années 70 dans les années 80
il y avait un soutien officiel des états
unis aux fondamentalistes islamistes
le sol est évidemment contre l'union
soviétique l'afghanistan c'est un
exemple que nous connaissons tous les
états unis ont volontairement 16 juillet
les fondamentalistes c'est ça qui a été
barrée d'enlèvement qu'est-ce qui a été
barrée dans le livre
oui principalement ces liens ces liens
qui existaient dans placé et qui sont un
petit peu gênante à l'heure actuelle
alors bob baer votre livre est dédié à
daniel pearl qui est le héros du dernier
livre de bernard henri lévy dont il est
venu parler ici alors bernard henri lévy
attirer l'attention sur le sur le
pakistan vous c'est l'arabie saoudite
alors l'arabie saoudite très simplement
pour nos amis téléspectateurs c'est un
quart des réserves de pétrole du monde
et c'est vrai que l'arrêt de
l'approvisionnement en pétrole saoudien
serait la mort d'une grave crise
mondiale
c'est pour ça en fait que depuis très
longtemps il ya une alliance entre les
états unis et l'arabie saoudite qui a
été signé au départ entre roosevelt et
le roi ibn saoud
en gros c'est ce que vous appelez
pétrole contre protection et la deuxième
raison de cette alliance c'est que les
saoudiens l'islam en général était un
rempart contre le communisme du temps de
la guerre froide c'est ça c'est ce qui
explique ce que vous appelez dans votre
bouquin l'aveuglément américain par
rapport à l'arabie saoudite
hier à wall et dire oui absolument en
fait il ya une dépendance totale de
l'économie américaine vis-à-vis de
l'arabie saoudite
prenons par exemple une grève au
venezuela les puits pétrole sont fermés
à ce moment là qui va compenser l'arabie
saoudite évidemment qui qui appuient
l'armée américaine et bien tout
simplement à l'arabie saoudite dans la
mesure où c'est leur premier acheteur
l'arabie saoudite investi des milliards
de dollars dans l'économie américaine
vous savez dès lors qu'il ya coutume ans
il est difficile de voir les choses en
face
donc il ya un lien qui date d'une
cinquantaine d'années entre l'arabie
saoudite et les etats unis pour des
raisons qu'on a vu et depuis le 11
septembre la réalité est apparu aux yeux
de tous c'est que la famille royale
saoudienne est totalement corrompu
complètement corrompu et pour garder le
pouvoir
elle finance des extrémistes c'est ça
c'est ça l'histoire a commencé par al
qaïda c'est simplement garder le pouvoir
il leur verse de l'argent aux
fondamentalistes consoeur pour se
protéger et puis leur dit faites vos
révolutions ailleurs en afrique en asie
en indonésie ou ailleurs mais pas ici
est bon le mieux la meilleure c'est que
ça a marché ou du concret mais en fait
il n'y a pas eu de difficultés en arabie
saoudite
le problème en fait c'est à washington
si vous voulez savoir toute la vérité
c'est que washington voit les choses
tout à fait différemment et donc le 11
septembre les américains ont été surpris
de voir qu'il y avait quinze
ressortissants en arabie saoudite dans
ses amis alors lénine avait dit les
capitalistes nous vendrons la corde pour
les pendre
finalement c'est un peu ce que font les
américains puisque l'attentât du world
trade center étaient financés finalement
avec de l'argent américain d'une
certaine façon absolument vous savez que
l'argent utilisé 11 septembre
dans le cas des attentats du 11
septembre avaient été prélevés en arabie
saoudite etc ayant il été réinjecté en
fait on fait son plein on fait le plein
de la voiture de sa voiture et bien on
donne de l'argent à qaïda alors bien
évidemment on peut toujours aussi le
savoir qui fait quoi et tu sais mais bon
c'est un fait
bernard et à gérer tout ça est vrai pour
le pétrole mais le pétrole c'est pas ce
nouvel argent américain c'est l'argent
du monde c'est notre argent c'est
l'argent tous les pays nous nous
fournissons
également on arabie saoudite je suis
très étonnant son bouquin c'est pourquoi
les américains sont ils victimes d'un un
tel aveuglement et ben vous dites parce
qu'ils sont corrompus eux aussi bien sur
le recyclage des pétrodollars mais aussi
tout un tas à washington de lobbyistes
de cabinet de relations publiques
d'avocats vous dites par exemple sur des
petits exemples mais le roi fahd envoie
un million de dollars à barbara bush
pour ses oeuvres en faveur de
l'alphabétisation par exemple vous dites
aussi une histoire qui est bien pire que
ça c'est qu'un jour cachot guy va dans
le ranch de nixon à san clemente en
californie
et puis en partant et l'oubli une valise
avec un million de dollars à l'intérieur
personne n'a lu avec l'âme il en déduit
ils en déduisent que finalement
washington est à vendre quoi
quelle est la solution pour régler le
problème de l'indicé ou dit alors au
départ on se dit la démocratie la
démocratie viendra à bout de de tous les
problèmes mais vous dites aujourd'hui
que s'il y avait des élections libres en
arabie saoudite finalement contenu la
nature du pays ça serait des islamistes
qui seraient élus et que l'arabie
séoudite de damas un pays comme comme
lui comme l'iran de khomeiny par exemple
je pense que c'est un peu prématuré de
parler démocratie qu'il faut mettre en
place en arabie saoudite l étal l'état
de droit dans un premier temps il faut
essayer d'aider les classes moyennes
pour qu'il y ait un accès un droit à la
propriété
c'est une première étape nécessaire
et puis il faut aussi se débarrasser de
toute cette corruption
c'est vraiment c'est ridicule ouais vous
dites banques bear donc finalement la
démocratie ce n'est pas la solution donc
la solution c'est quoi c'est
l'intervention militaire contre l'arabie
saoudite
le devoir d'ingérence écoutez à la fin
du livre je fais un petit raccourci je
dis que si le pays fait faillite et bien
ce moment là on peut pas
on a besoin de ce pétrole pour des
raisons de sécurité mais ce qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait cédé réformes au
sein du pays il y a une elle qui
souhaite réformer le pays c'est celle
représentée par le prince héritier est
ce que c'est beau père est ce que c'est
parce qu'ils sentent que l'attitude des
etats-unis à leur égard est enfin de
changer que l'arabie saoudite se
rapproche on l'a vu cette semaine se
rapproche de la russie où je pense que
l'arabie saoudite se rend bien compte
que en train de dire clairement que dans
les relations entre les deux pays vont
de mal en pis une superpuissance qui
d'un coup tu que tel un dinosaure pour
elle et je pense que l'arabie saoudite
est en train de rechercher de nouveaux
alliés que ce soit la russie où l'europe
ou les états unis n'oublient jamais il
ne faut jamais oublier que les états
unis ont été profondément blessée par
les attentats du 11 septembre c'est un
fait les américains inquiéter vraiment
touché et donc il est clair aux yeux des
américains et aux yeux du reste du monde
d'ailleurs que tout le monde sait que
nous ayons sûr réagi en quelque sorte
et donc on se rend bien compte que cela
a affecté la relation avec l'arabie
saoudite
alors quand vous parlez des états unis
ce qui est le plus inquiétant à mon sens
c'est que vous dites qu'ils sont
tellement corrompu par l'argent saoudien
qu'on voit pas très bien comment il
pourrait s'arrêter d'être aveugle et
d'une certaine façon
alors qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
les états unis un sursaut mais les
médias aux états unis maintenant son
trait embrigader on voit bien il n'y a
plus qu'une seule voix qui parle
il ya aux états unis de plus en plus
d'arrestations arbitraires l'habeas
corpus qui est la base de notre
démocratie et est remis en cause aux
états unis alors j'aurai me posais une
question bob r une question qui a été
posée cette semaine à la une d'un
magazine qui s'appelle marianne qui le
magazine de jean françois kahn
bonne mère
est ce que vous croyez sérieusement
aujourd'hui que les etats-unis sont
encore une démocratie
ah oui mais à peine
encore une attaque et cette attaque
pourrait avoir des dommages irréparables
des conséquences très graves
je pense que tout le monde s'en
inquiètent donc l'amérique est à peine
une démocratie ni vos états unis sont
toujours une démocratie mais il y avait
une un saccage de plus à ce moment là
montré un certain nombre de 3 à 6 par
est déjà le cas à l'heure actuelle mais
y aurait par exemple ce serait par
exemple de la fin du premier amendement
est un perte et de la presse dans une
situation délicate à l'heure actuelle et
les choses qu'on rêve
les choses pourraient empirer mais
espérons que tel ne sera pas le cas on
allume
je rappelle le film the sleeper en noir
une maison blanche dan ar non c'est
quand même curieux qu'on s'en aperçoive
maintenant tout le monde sait depuis 25
ans que les saoudi les saoudiens ne
persécute ou le monde que les droits de
l'homme ne sont pas respectés que les
femmes peuvent pas conduire que tout ça
est épouvantable découvrir cela juste un
vrai passionné mais les fans qui
connaissent pas c'est pas mal bernard
sauf que maintenant en plus sont des
copies finances d'al qaïda à tout le
monde de sa veste avec eux qu'ils ont
fait l'afghanistan les talibans et
cetera donc on découvre pas ça
maintenant parce que c'était vraiment la
fable normalement je vais je réussir un
livre comme ça vous vous a créé des
ennemis dangereux ce serait difficile
d'en faire la liste voyez vous il ya
tellement de gens qui sont furieux
furieux on va retirer leur lot de
l'habitation
ah non en fait ma famille et au proche
orient
mais bon les gens ne vont pas chercher à
se venger contre une famille proche
orient mais bon c'est ma responsabilité
je l'assumé si mal je voulais c'est
parti avec bob bull et bear mamour sa
loge du moyen-orient du liban merci
beaucoup
d'accord
bernard il a fait dire au revoir conax
veut pas dire ghana n'a pas dit au
revoir
bernard oui bernard whitacre a dit au
revoir aux mêmes heures d'avis
en fanfare
ciao
nous enseignons
mieux comme ça normal
alors
et ça c'est de la merde
bernard evein nous rappelle bernard
super bowl et prennent avec b